dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fajir I think this is
one of the more important things that
happened in AI research lately in the
last few years we have seen deepmind
defeat the best goal players in the
world and after open a eyes venture in
the game of dota 2 it's time for deep
mind to shine again as they take on
Starcraft 2 the realtime strategy game
the depth and the amount of skill
required to play this game is simply
astounding the search space of starcraft
2 is so vast that it exceeds both chess
and even go by a significant margin also
it is a game that requires a great deal
of mechanical skill split-second
decision-making and we have imperfect
information as we only see what our
units can see a nightmare situation for
any AI deep mind invited a beloved pro
player PLO to play a few games against
their new Starcraft 2 AI that goes by
the name alpha star note that TLO is a
professional player who is easily in the
top 1% of players or even better meet
grandmaster for those who play Starcraft
2 this video is about what happened
during this event and later I will make
another video that describes the
algorithm that was used to create this
AI the paper is still under review so it
will take a little time until I can get
my hands on it at the end of this video
you will also see the inner workings of
this AI let's dive in this is an AI that
looked at a few games played by human
players and after that initial step it
learned by playing itself for about 200
years in our next episode you will see
how this is even possible so I hope you
are subscribed to the series you see
here that the AI controls 2 blue units
and TLO the human player plays red right
at the start of the first game the AI
did something interesting in fact what
is interesting is what it didn't do it
started to create new buildings next to
its Nexus instead of building a wall off
that you can see
here using a Wolof is considered
standard practice in most games in the a
I used these buildings to not wall off
the entrance but shield away the workers
from possible attacks now note that this
is not unheard of but this is also not a
strategy that is widely played today and
is considered non-standard it also built
more worker units than what is
universally accepted as standard we
found out later that this was partly
done in anticipation of losing a few of
them early on very cool then almost
before we even knew what happened it won
the first game a little more than seven
minutes in which is very quick noting
that in game time is a little faster
than real time
[Applause]
the thought process of TLO at this point
is that that's interesting but okay well
the AI plays aggressively and managed to
pull this one off no big deal we will
fire up the second game and in the
meantime a few interesting details the
goal of setting up the details of this
algorithm was that the number of actions
performed by the AI roughly matches a
human player and hopefully it still
plays as well or better it has to make
meaningful strategic decisions you see
here that this checks out for the
average actions every minute but if you
look here you see around the tail end
here that there are times when it
performs more actions than humans and
this may enable play styles that are not
accessible for human players however
note that many times it also does
miraculous things with very few actions
now what about another important detail
reaction time the reaction time of the
AI is set to 350 milliseconds which is
quite slow that's excellent news because
this is usually a common angle of
criticism for game guys
the AI also sees the whole map at once
but it is not given more information
than what its units can see this perhaps
is the most commonly misunderstood
detail so it is worth noting so in other
words it sees exactly what a human would
see if the human would move the camera
around very quickly but it doesn't have
to move the camera which adds additional
actions and cognitive load to the human
so one might say that the AI has an edge
here the AI plays these games
independently what's more each game was
played by a different AI which also
means that they do not memorize what
happened in the last game like a human
would early in the next game we can see
the utility of the Wolof in action which
is able to completely prevent the AI as
early attack later that game the AI use
disrupters the unit which if controlled
with such level of expertise can
decimate the army of the opponent with
area damage by killing multiple units at
once it has done an outstanding job
picking away at the army of TLO then
after getting a significant advantage
alpha star who loses it with a few
sloppy plays and by deciding to engage
aggressively while standing in tight
choke points you can see that this is
not such a great idea this was quite
surprising as this is considered to be
Starcraft 101 knowledge right there
during the remainder of the match the
commentators mentioned that they play
and watch games all the time and the AI
came up with an army composition that
they have never seen during a
professional match and the AI won this
one too after this game it became clear
that these agents can play any style in
the game which is terrifying here you
can see an alternative visualization
that shows a little more of the inner
workings of the neural network we can
see what information it gets from the
game the visualization of neurons that
get activated within the network what
locations and units are considered for
the next actions and whether the AI
predicts itself as the winner or the
loser of the game if you look carefully
you will also see the moment when the
agent becomes certain that it will win
this game I could look at this all day
long and if you feel the same way
make sure to visit the video description
I have a link to the source video for
you the final result against elo was 5
to 0
I actually lost everything all over fire
matches so that's something and he
mentioned that alpha star played very
much like a human does and almost always
managed to outmaneuver him
however TLO also mentioned that he is
confident that upon playing more
training matches against these agents he
would be able to defeat the AI I hope he
will be given a chance to do that this
AI seems strong but still beatable I
would also note that many of you would
probably expect the later versions of
alpha star to be way better than this
one the good news is that the story
continues and we'll see whether that's
true so at this point the deep mind
scientist said maybe we could try to be
a bit more ambitious and asked can you
bring us someone better and in the
meantime pressed the training button on
the AI again in comes mana a top-tier
pro player one of the best Protoss
players in the world this was a
nerve-wracking moment for deep mind
scientists as well because their agents
played against each other so they only
knew the ars win rate against a
different AI but they didn't know how
they would compete against a top pro
player it may still have holes in its
strategy who knows what would happen
understandably they had very little
confidence in winning this one what they
didn't expect is that the new AI was not
slightly improved or somewhat improved
no no no no no this new AI was next
level this set of improved agents among
many other skills had incredibly crisp
micromanagement of each individual unit
in the first game we've seen it pulling
back injured units but still letting
them attack from afar masterfully
leading to an early win for the AI
against mana in the first game he and
the commentators were equally shocked by
how well the agent played and I will add
that I remember from watching many games
from a now inactive player by the name
marine King a few years ago and I
vividly remembered that he played some
of his games so well the commentator
said that there is no better way to put
it he
played like a god I am almost afraid to
say that this micromanagement was even
more crisp than that this AI plays
phenomenal games in later matches the a
I did thinks that seemed like blunders
like attacking on ramps and standing in
choke points or using unfavorable unit
compositions and refusing to change it
and get this it's still won all of those
games five to zero against the top pro
player let the competition was closed by
a match where the a I was asked to also
do the camera management the agent was
still very competent but somewhat weaker
and as a result lost this game
hence the zero or one part in the title
my impression is that it was asked to do
something that it was not designed for
and expect a future version to be able
to handle this use case as well
I will also command mana for his solid
game plan for this game and also huge
respect for deep mind for their
sportsmanship interestingly in this
match mana also started a worker
oversaturation strategy that I mentioned
earlier this he learned from alpha star
and used it in his winning game isn't
that amazing deepmind also offered a
reddit AMA where anyone could ask them
questions to make sure to clear up any
confusion for instance the actions per
minute part has been addressed I've
included a link to that for you in the
video description to go from a
turn-based perfect information game like
go to a real-time strategy game of
imperfect information in about a year
sounds like science fiction to me and
yet here it is also note that deep Minds
goal is not to create a guide like
Starcraft 2 AI they want to solve
intelligence not Starcraft 2 and they
use this game as a vehicle to
demonstrate its
long-term decision-making capabilities
against human players one more important
thing to emphasize is that the building
blocks of alpha star are meant to be
reasonably general AI algorithms which
means that parts of this AI can be
reused for other things for instance
demis hassabis mentioned weather
prediction and climate modeling as
examples if you take only one thought
from this video let it be this one I
urge you to watch all the matches
because what you're witnessing may very
well be history in the making
I put a link to the whole event in the
video description plus plenty more
materials including other people's
analysis manners personal experience of
the event his breakdown of his games and
what was going through his head during
the event I highly recommend checking
out his fifth game but really go through
them all it's a ton of fun I made sure
to include a more skeptical analysis of
the game as well to give you a balanced
portfolio of insights also huge respect
for deep mind and the players who
practice their chops for many many years
and have played really well under
immense pressure thank you all for this
delightful event it really made my day
and the ultimate question is how long
did it take to train these agents two
weeks Wow
and what's more after the training step
the AI can be deployed on an inexpensive
consumer desktop machine and this is
only the first version this is just a
taste and it would be hard to overstate
how big of a milestone this is and now
scientists studied might have sufficient
data to calculate the amount of
resources they need to spend to train
the next even more improved agents I am
confident that they will also take into
consideration the feedback from the
Starcraft community when creating this
next version what a time to be alive
what do you think about all this any
predictions is this harder than dota 2
let me know in the comment section below
and remember we humans build up new
strategies by learning from each other
and of course the AI as you have seen
here doesn't care about any of that
it doesn't need intuition and can come
up with unusual strategies the
difference now is that these strategies
were
against some of the best human players
now it's time for us to finally start
learning from an AI GG thanks for
watching and for your generous support
now see you next time